Демидів. Невелике село, яке затопили наприкінці лютого,
щоби врятувати… величезний Київ.
Росіяни звідси втекли ще 31 березня, а ось вода й дотепер не відступила.
Бачте, фундамент… Ото воно розмиває. Бачте, які щілини?
Це воно буде все сипатися і просідати… Чи завалиться. Я не знаю.
Хата пані Тетяни простояла затопленою понад пів року. І хоча з подвір'я
воду вдалося відкачати - руйнувати фундамент продовжують підземні води.
А от у сусідньому будинку фундамент вцілів, утім під підлогою оселилися… жаби.
Віктор розповідає, що сотні земноводних атакували оселю.
Як вода начала спадати - жаби пішли. Їх же було по всьому селу повно,
земляні такі невеличкі.
Підняв я ганчірку, що я там витирав, а їх там аж кишить.
Як почали ми їх ловити, так кругом вигрібати по всій хаті, то просто жах, що було.
Не можна передати. Позабивав підлогу - почали мені під підлогою співати.
Співають під підлогою. Крекчуть.
Поступово кількість жаб під будинком зменшилася, а частина з них
переселилася у погріб, де вода стоїть вже майже рік.
Наче трохи добавилось знову, сніг розтав.
То була по ту сходинку, а це вже піднялася сантиметрів на 25.
Тим часом у пані Тетяни ситуація не краща… ще й погріб почав руйнуватися.
Це ж воно 10 місяців у воді. Воно ж для цього не розраховане.
Це ж двері, бачте, вже відірвались, поплили. Далі стіни почнуть руйнуватись.
Хата пані Тетяни розташована поряд із греблею, яка нині відділяє село від великої води.
Наприкінці лютого, щоб зупинити наступ росіян, ЗСУ підірвали дамбу:
тоді вода з Київського водосховища хлинула до річки Ірпінь й стрімко наповнила її заплаву.
Гребля між заплавою і селом почала підтікати, а однією з перших на шляху води
була оселя пані Тетяни. Ось що жінка розповідала DW у червні.
Виходиш, отак метрів два і добавляється вода... Тут росіяни були, стріляють,
і вода підступає. Ми не знали, що робить.
І хоча відтоді минуло сім місяців, пані Тетяна каже, змінилося небагато.
Город постійно затоплений, а з настанням холодів - перетворився на крижаний каток.
У криниці вода все ще жовтого кольору, а проблема з довозом питної - досі не вирішена.
Нам возили, а тоді перестали возить. Сказали: машина зламалась.
Так і не возять. Ну беру в сестри, сестра привозить, купує. У нас там бабуся Марія ходить,
в колодязі бере питну воду. Теж не знаю, яка там якість тої води.
Хто фільтри поставив. Уже хто як у нас викручується.
Замість вже звичного озера на подвір'ї тепер… болото.
На початку року завдяки безперебійній роботі помп з підтопленого села
вдалося помітно відкачати воду. В Демидові світло нині не вимикають,
адже щойно насоси зупиняться - у село знову хлине потік.
І стримати його лише бензиновими помпами не вдасться.
Майже затопило… Ця дорога була залита водою, ми думали, що знов вода наступить.
Потім нам ще сільська рада купила бензинову помпу.
Поставили ще її. І ще дві електричні качали. І тоді почала вода відкачуватися.
А так уже близько була, вода цю дорогу перекрила й вода знов прибувала назад.
Спочатку паливо для помпи місцеві мешканці купували переважно власним коштом.
Лік йшов на десятки тисяч гривень, розповідає пан Віктор.
Ну ми тоді давали, деякі й по десять тисяч, по шість тисяч, по п’ять.
Хто скільки міг - той стільки й давав.
І хоча постраждалим від великої води разово виплатили по двадцять тисяч гривень,
ця сума аж ніяк не компенсує витрат демидівців за одинадцять місяців підтоплення.
Пан Віктор каже: двадцять тисяч пішло лише на заміну підлоги в літній кухні.
А роботи непочатий край, особливо в будинку. Під підлогою й досі вода.
Під підлогою звичайно є. Ну я позабивав, позакривав. Все забив, все накрив.
Усі щілини позамазував, ну від жаб нема спокою.
А пані Тетяна двадцять тисяч компенсації витратила на корм і сіно,
адже земельний пай, який раніше годував худобу, пішов під воду.
Пай тепер у воді й випас у воді. Все в воді. І тепер вже не знаю, що далі буде.
Було таке, що мені люди трохи помогли. По телебаченню побачили й помогли,
й сіно давали безкоштовно. Подзвонили, що приїдь й забери.
Цьогоріч місцевим жителям вперше довелося купувати картоплю й іншу городину.
Через надмірну вологу люди залишилися без врожаю, який зазвичай їх годував увесь рік.
Що у нас змінилося?..  Абсолютно нічого. Вода пішла, а всі дерева пропали.
Все пропало, нема жодного дерева. Городи пахати не будеш, бо сирість,
вода стоїть під верхом.
Місцеві кажуть: якби хоча б на півтора метра дозволили знизити рівень води в заплаві,
то вода з городів і погребів відійшла б сама. Проте на численні звернення
сільської влади до державних органів відповідь єдина: заплава має залишатися
наповненою в оборонних цілях, така позиція військових.
Тож перед людьми постає вибір: призвичаїтися до сусідства
з великою водою чи покидати свої домівки.
І навіть не хочеться нікуди, якщо чесно. Дім є дім. Навіть як прийшли сюди росіяни,
а чого я маю йти з хати? Я не хочу з дому йти. Якби вже там якась ситуація була,
но я з дому не хочу. Це моя земля.
Єдине, що зараз рятує село від затоплення, - насоси, які працюють завдяки
безперебійній подачі струму. Про можливі ракетні атаки росіян по енергетичній системі
тут бояться навіть думати.
Адже з кожною годиною без світла Демидів дедалі більше йтиме під воду.